[Music]
there's no Jam reset I do think you get
rewarded way too much for way too little
work there is no escape I've done pretty
well against Isis before
[Music]
or stock nothing we'll see
it's okay hey let's like eat by the car
no amount of [ __ ] mass will help you
get away from them read in hell that is
wobbling it's happening
how'd it happen how do people not see it
okay laying it on he does not mind
staying and playing on the shield and
tuna gets the wobble yeah this should be
it
Oh This Is It this is it
problem is over half double jumps over
there yeah all right last soccer club
how long are they allowed to do this - I
don't know if it deserves that the rules
that wobbling is the hey everyone before
we get any further into the video I just
want to tell you that if you want to see
more melee content like this video then
make sure to LIKE the video and sub to
the channel means a lot and we're
definitely listening anyway for over a
decade
wobbling has divided the smash community
depending on who you ask
it's either the only thing keeping a
weak character in the meta or a horrible
cheese strat that could have ruined
melee forever but what is wobbling
wobbling is Malee's most dangerous
controversial and infamous infinite
combo people really don't like it oh we
rolled into it that's a very very very
expensive roll yeah yeah that hate what
it's like all right now checking Twitter
tweet ahem
Wow my man is on social media right now
the main reason that people dislike
wobbling is that it's boring to watch
they don't they think it's degenerate
they think it's it's unfair and it in a
boost low level player skill so wobbling
is a technique unique to the ice
climbers in melee but it's not the only
thing unique about this unlike any other
character in the game picking ice
climbers actually gives you access to
two characters at once you play as Popo
while the AI controls nana who follows
you around and copies your movements as
a character ice climbers are pretty weak
they get a lot out of just one grab but
their grab range is really short making
them weak against characters who can
keep them out like peach and Samus on
top of that nana is an idiot and will
kill herself for absolutely no reason
that will leave you with just Popo who's
pretty bad on his own
but when you have both ice climbers you
can do some pretty crazy things feet
usually Nana just moves around and
copies your movement but once you
distinct the queue ice climbers they
open up a wealth of possibilities
they have huge hitboxes great movement
and
most importantly wobbly wobbling is the
name for an infinite combo that's been
around since the early days of
competitive mail this man
what's the W his name starts with a w w
that's right his sponsor also has the W
with it shoutouts to ethics one job
laughs X game exchange man there's a bit
of finesse to it but basically what
happens is that one ice climber grabs
you hits you and then the other ice
climber grabs you and hits you before
you can do anything and escape the grab
they then do this over and over and over
again until you've racked up enough
damage that they kill you on one throw
all off one touch basically anyone who
wears the timing for this gains access
to the game's deadliest infinite combo
[Applause]
problem is over half the guy that falls
might be out of this you know it you
know I'm done fine
I'll see you later oh-oh-oh nope nope
nope less most walks off you try to done
this he is oh he's he's salivating a
selfie yep yes you got the flash off and
use Twitter is on screen if you want to
check it out does give the fist bumps
you have respectful
there is no other technique in the game
that kills as consistently from one
touch as wobbling so much though that
some people see it as an easy way to
beat up on inexperienced players if
you're up against the ice climbers you
are constantly afraid you make one
mistake and you get wobbled oh you had
to fade back yet nowhere else to go
all of that is gonna do it Lana's gonna
be an attending
[Music]
all right ten new kidding his sweet
revenge wobbling reputation for being
high reward with the low effort on top
of having virtually no counter play has
made it one of the most controversial
subjects in smash first of all I want to
say yes I do believe wobbling is
incredibly boring
I do think you get rewarded way too much
for weight too little work especially at
low level low and mid level but even a
pretty high level also you get to
rewarded Tom with iceice because of the
wobble because this is what happened
done Stu's done Steve love let's tease
it's okay don't do it
grab wobbling has been around for well
over a decade at this point I sees
players in Japan discovered it in the
early 2000s and once it made its way to
the West the debate began to rage the
question was simply ban wobbling or keep
it illegal
so was first discovered shoe that picked
it up I don't know if he's gonna be this
but he picked up wobbling and he told me
that he thinks wobbling is broken and it
should be bent but he's gonna use it
anyway because it helps him so that
that's one of the reasons I think it's
more justifiable
this is broken should we ban the
community just couldn't come to
consensus some tournaments banned
wobbling others kept it legal wobbling
was basically trapped in purgatory and
the community is still split on the
issue been wobbling - I think it's weird
like why are people not like just doing
stuff to make the game more interesting
and more fun to watch what's wrong with
being wobbling so for Malto reasons i've
always liked it against this I've been
against it's like the past 10 years I
can't really see justification for
banning banning wobbling I've done
pretty well against Isis before I've
stated that I don't like wobbling but I
have also previously been against
banning wobbling wobbling I get it I see
both sides the wobbling gets banned I
agree and if wobbling doesn't get banned
I agree it's gone to the point where
some people say that wobbling is bad
form a way see the argument goes
something like this if anything is gonna
make you click out of twitch while
you're watching Mele it's wobbling and
if you're clicking out of twitch that
means Malee's viewership numbers are
going down that's bad for the top
players it's bad for tournaments and
it's bad for the scene in general oh he
had to pay back yet nowhere else to go
all of that is gonna do it
when is going to be an attending club
taking the civil waters yeah I have not
even holding the controller all right
and then 10 you kidding his sweet
revenge and that is gonna do it I was a
little bit of salt but there is another
side to the argument there are people
who believe that wobbling should stay
legal people who believe that without
wobbling ice climber has become
irrelevant and it's not fair to just ban
an entire character out of the game
because if you've been welding against
puff against peach and against amis and
Luigi where you basically have no hand
off combos you basically mean delete I
cease from the game and if you look at
tournaments in the last few years where
wobbling was legal well you don't see
all ice climbers in the top eight not
because people have made some sort of
pact not to play the character but
because just not that good old airsoft
grabs one out of there
like that you're I think he's playing
training mode right now he don't care I
can't see these don't be yeah and as for
the tournaments that do ban wobbling
well it should go without saying but if
you ban the ice climbers strongest
weapon then in Popo get pretty bad
you know if ice climbers don't have this
tactic they're really not a great
character and there's not much they can
do in this current met it with kids like
fox falco toffee you know that was sort
of the argument like they sort of they
need it right and let alone against
floating matchups like peach and puffs
if I see stiff ice climbers don't have
wobbling I'm not sure viably that they
can really really have any shot against
a top-level peach or Jigglypuff but even
with all that wobbling remained in
purgatory it was banned at some
tournaments legal with others and I sees
players rarely made topics until
everything changed straight hit the
straight up smash can still
crowd roaring so PO right now people
again oh okay of smash you thinking why
Ivana uh but this one is just beat our
bottom
that's eyes Rijo I think that's a [ __ ]
who gains two one
yeah mangos looking out of breath
he doesn't even need the waffle discuss
it but he gets it anyway early career
wire into the bananas his up to Owens
group right now no he's gonna G beat he
beat two gods and he's in winner's
bracket he's gonna host it to the Sunday
bracket in the winter side yeah he
coasted over the last few years ice
climbers mains have made a resurgence
first chewed at made it to eleventh
place in 2017 and then bananas broke
into the top 20 in 2019 after the sudden
influx of a C's players doing well at
tournaments
a flurry of social media post announced
that regions all over the US were
banning wobbling starting with Tennessee
in a matter of days wobbling was getting
banned all over the place eventually it
turned out that the whole Tennessee
thing was a hoax but that didn't stop
the bans after a while even major
tournaments got in on the action
Gamow pound and most recently the smash
World Tour all banned wobbling for some
context the smash World Tour encompasses
pretty much every major mainly
tournament in the world and every pro
wants to enter for the huge prize pool
wobbling I just be dead now it's gonna
kill the ice commerce scene it's
literally gonna kill them it's a lot of
most of them are gonna quit there you're
either gonna quit or they're gonna
change characters as fewer and fewer
major tournaments allow wobbling the
future of the ice climbers has gotten
pretty hazy ice climbers have become
kind of a boogeyman in May away there is
a huge chunk of the community that is
terrified of what will happen if I cease
run rampant and every Grand Finals
becomes I seize versus puffs a horrible
boring snooze fest and there are no
rules to prevent this kind of stalling
today oh he's got it
because he's not stalling he's actually
in a totally hittable position it's just
that it this isn't even wobbling like
wobbling doesn't help you happy but ice
climbers and wobbling have already made
it unto melees biggest stage and it led
to one of the hypest tournaments in
melee history wobbles is the guy that
wobbling is named after he didn't invent
the technique but he's the one who made
it popular
just can't get away
why get away incredible escape I'm going
to evo2013 wobbles was kinda looking to
retire he was hoping to end his time
playing competitive melee with a happy
memory at the biggest tournament the
game had ever seen what he didn't expect
to do was go on an insane run to the
loser's bracket meeting some of the best
players in the world with ice climbers
that's what I was about to say to the
favorites program finals we're gonna
beat each other to lose his bracket and
see what mango does here he's asking rid
of Nana h7c has so many hobbies is going
to talk a bit late you're upset okay
yeah it's dad always misses the handoff
but sailor wobbles wins explain the
words finals here evolution 2013 oh that
we almost had an opportunity there a lot
of wait doctors have a shield joining
him out
finals Arizona has done it the ice club
has happened free one by one wobbles
bubbled the gods of smash making it all
the way to the grand finals wobbles made
out of one but his run was legendary
it's gone down in melee history possibly
his last tournament that's quite enough
to go out on picks out - wobbles up
until like wobbles came about and I
think it was Eva 2013 when he got second
place and he wobbled like all the top
players that was the only time somebody
has ever used wobbly to its full
potential and actually you know was able
to quote-unquote break the game and with
with wobbling melee was kind of in a
tenuous place sure he vote 2013 was huge
but it was huge because everybody loved
watching melee they rediscovered the
game because of that tournament wobbling
they didn't kill it and wobbles
definitely didn't look like a guy
getting carried by wobbles good job whoa
do it again
well slow down let's go to the next game
and look the meta has changed a lot
since then
PUF is way more of a threat and we've
already told you that pop versus ICS is
the most boring thing you could possibly
watch but wall bows prove that ice
climbers are more than just wobbling and
his legacy is being carried forward now
by players like bananas and even shooter
that will probably be it any styles
controller down OPM it seems like
wobbling is gonna be banned pretty much
everywhere going forward but those ice
climbers players have spent years of
their lives mastering every facet of
their character and now they're gonna
have to prove that the ice climbers can
survive a world without wobbling so I I
just I just plan on improving my met my
my mental game my my my punish game
especially my punish game I have to put
out and put in a lot a lot more work on
my punish game
and from now on from here on out ins got
to practice playing smash without
without wobbling he's gonna be a huge
like mind shift for me it's gonna be
completely different
yo Mac can you dad for me on camera Matt
please dad oh you guys can't see it oh
oh he's gonna do it he's gonna do it
he's gonna do it get them it was for the
people that was variable love it your
adoring fans
[Music]